adam
i just met this guy
climate scientist we're doing storms
tonight
particular kind of storm what kind
hurricanes hurricane but we need a drink
for the night but there's already like a
hurricane drink what is a hurricane it's
a rum drink with fruit punch beef
specific it's three kinds of rum like
spicy dark with cherry juice you would
have to have rum because the places
where they drink rum they have
hurricanes a lot okay but i don't want
to be so boring as to just have a
hurricane because we're going to focus a
little bit tonight on hurricane sandy
because i got hit by sandy i live in
long beach i got hit by sandy
so
is there something
sandy you could put in the drink like we
could say shovel and go outside but i
don't think anyone's gonna buy it um
he's gonna put sand in the drink so
maybe a sandy hurricane if you could let
something look muddy and dark on the
bottom of the glass muddy and dark like
what like uh like a cassis at the bottom
and then pour the drink on top that'll
look like purple because we'll sink to
the bottom because it's sugarier
yeah
and
that'll be a muddy
hurricane that'll give the the color and
the sweetness then we can just do ice so
the water and vodka
you want to see one yeah let's just try
one
i have to test
because
maybe
you can say it but maybe it doesn't
taste good is there some liquor with
sand something that sounds like sand in
the name
that's got sand in the name
sand
witches
a drink with a sandwich
i'm told there was an earl or sandwich
who wanted to eat all his food
groups
in a single bite
so what do you got here
that's the you can see sitting on the
bottom that's the cassis on the bottom
and then just a
vodka soda sitting on top of it bucka
soda
so this is a sandy vodka thing but it
wouldn't have the rum we could do
rubbish you want to do except sandy hit
us up here in the northeast
not not the like the caribbean right
we've
he's a hurricane expert so
his opinion matters here
needs more grit
but drinks don't have grit
no
not for a while
another way you can go with it is since
sandy was a tropical hurricane and then
combined with a hexatropical winter
storm you could do the tropical thing
and put something or
northern climate on top of this so we
abandoned the sandy reference it will
just be hurricane more conception
more conceptually hurricane plus
nor'easter
so we get a room called the northeast
i don't know i've never encountered it
if there is
why is the grain that came from the
northeast so that tends to be the the
the base if you're thinking in northeast
cocktail if you ride right
we could do rye and ginger beer that's a
dark and stormy but with rye instead of
the rum making it a northeast storm sort
of thing
[Music]
can we try that thank you
you can get the bartender in this too
because he's the one dude making it
you get your name for the account
my name is dirk dirk
that is a bartender name for you can you
do a special drink every time
for every yeah
and then we try to give a discount for
it okay ingredients now this is uh this
is a rye and just ginger beer very
simple rye and ginger beer
wow
that's fun
i forgot how punchy ginger beer yeah
yeah it makes a difference
nice
okay so
how would we market this this would be
the northeast stormy the north so stormy
is there stormy weather drink already or
this this is if this was drum this would
be the darkest story which is a
caribbean thing the technical term would
be extra tropical transition
that's a mouthful for just a cocktail
this is an extra tropical transition it
might be correct yeah you'll sell one
drink tonight right yeah get them out of
here
okay now
okay uh so
i like this this has got this my hair is
growing let's do it i grew four extra
hairs on my chest
on this
let's have the camera guy taste it here
you taste it
okay so we this would be because rye has
a northeast origin yeah which i didn't
know
it's the grain that you would find up
here to distill yes more commonly than
any other okay so what what is the the
rye
where's this made
i'm not sure
right okay
old overhault
all right so it's rye with ginger beer
so this gives a kind of
this this combines the northeast with
some tropical right the ginger beer is
actually like jamaican or something
fine
so we have to name this
let's name this
hurricane sammy
let's name it
i was thinking something like
the tropical look
but it doesn't bring the northeast into
it so
how about
do you have any ideas
oh yeah
the
in a minute we got to like finish this
people are trickling in they're gonna
open everyone's piled outside we gotta
get this done now
so
i like the northeast stormy that's to
the point it's got the storm in it it's
got the northeast reference it's also
how about let's why don't we go old
school
and just simply call it
stormy weather
so how about that
the stormy weather rye with ginger beer
the northeast and the caribbean
we all partake
when the times come all right in stormy
weather
let's get some of these so
[Music]
do you change that yet i did yeah yeah
thank you for joining me
on star talks
creation
of the drink of the night
because tonight we're talking about
storms and he's the expert
everything i know is because i've lived
through them and everything he knows is
because he studies them
as a climate scientist
scientists climate scientists it's all
good what
is interesting about atmosphere if not
climate change well we distinguish
between the climate and the weather the
climate
but but i'm distinguishing between
climate and just atmosphere
why study the atmosphere unless you're
going to focus on climate we could focus
on the weather both either right good
so you're a climate weather scientist
right
and any climate of weather happens in an
atmosphere
i'm a little bit focused on the tropics
okay he's got his head up in the
stratosphere here we'll see you during
the show
there you go thank you
guys dirk
always a pleasure
so we'll make a note of this i'll
announce it on stage rick just went with
his little notes he's going to princess
of signs they have here good there's a
little discount on it or something yeah
yeah okay we knocked like a buck off for
the big special perfect thanks
bye